do you run distributed workloads on
kubernetes or gke if so you are probably
having to manage more and more services
and it's getting harder or harder to
understand what's going on if there are
any issues
this is where a service mesh can help a
service mesh is a dedicated
infrastructure layer that you can add to
your clusters it gives you capabilities
like observability traffic management
and security without having to modify
application code my name is yer i'm an
sre at google cloud and today i'm going
to show you how to use both the open
source version of the istio service mesh
and google's managed antho service mesh
to get better observability for your
services running on gke this is
engineering for reliability
the istio service mesh works by adding
android proxy side cars to your services
running on gke these proxies intercept
all service to service traffic in the
mesh and enable the application aware
features like security traffic
management and routing and observability
this is the data plan the control plane
dynamically programs the proxy side cars
updating them as the rules or the
environment change
your first option for using istio on gke
is to simply install the open source
distribution in your cluster this is the
way to go if you prefer to have the most
control over your deployment or if you
have existing dependencies on features
that may not yet be available in
google's managed offer
istio includes an open source
observability toolkit you can use
prometheus for metrics and zipkin or
jaeger for analyzing tracing you can
also enable proxy access logs and have
the proxy sidecars write out logs for
every request in the mesh let's have a
look at how you can use this toolkit and
centralize all that telemetry to cloud
operations
in our example we have an application
running in the istio demo namespace
we have the istio control plane and
observability components running in the
istio system namespace
this includes prometheus from metrics
and kiali for observing traffic in the
mesh
if for example we want to look at the
request rate for our services in the
mesh
we can use the istioctl dashboard
dashboard prometheus command
[Music]
and run equality like this
if we want to visualize how traffic
flows between the different services in
the mesh we can use kiowa
[Music]
at each node
we can see how much traffic the service
is seeing and what the response time
looks like
finally we can enable request logging
for the envoy sicar proxies by using the
telemetry api
we can then view those logs in the
terminal
now let's have a look at how we can get
this telemetry into cloud operations
to adjust the prometheus metrics we can
actually use google's managed prometheus
binary
just by replacing this image tag
this allows us to query prometheus
metrics in metrics explorer
[Music]
here's that same request right query
the proxy sidecar request logs are
automatically adjusted into cloud
logging
and we can query those too
so through the combination of google's
managed service for prometheus and cloud
logging we can get metric and log
telemetry generated by istio ingested
into cloud operations and use it just
like other telemetry from your
infrastructure and services
if you want to maximize control over
your issue deployment and possibly have
experience with istio already using the
open source distribution is the right
way to go however if you're new to using
a service mesh or would simply like a
more managed experience there's the end
of service mesh or asm it's a tested and
supported distribution of istio giving
you all the benefits of a service mesh
with full google support
if you'd like to control version
upgrades yourself or have existing
integrations you depend on you can
deploy asm with an in-cluster control
plane let's have a look at such a
deployment and how it automatically
sends telemetry to cloud operations
let's first have a look at our cluster
the control plane pods are running in
the istio system namespace just like
what we had when we installed open
source sdm
[Music]
our application pods are also
instrumented with the istio proxy
containers
now let's have a look at the telemetry
that the anta service mesh collects
[Music]
the enthalpy service mesh homepage in
the cloud console has a list of the
services that are running in the mesh in
our cluster
we can select a service and get some
basic information about it
like request rates
error rate
and average latency
the topology view here shows us how the
service sends and receives traffic
the metrics screen allows us to see
these metrics over time broken down by
various dimensions
finally we can get error logs for our
service by going to the diagnostics
screen
we can click out to the logs explorer to
get more details about these error logs
this is also where we can view the
access logs for our services
[Music]
we can get more metric telemetry in
cloud monitor
for example we can run a query like this
to get a breakdown of request rates by
service
so this is how you can use telemetry
automatically ingested from the
in-cluster asm control plane to
understand the behavior and health of
your services
if you're just starting out with istio
or would like to use a fully managed
service you can use managed asm in this
deployment model the control plane is
fully managed by google and does not run
in your cluster it does mean that some
features like custom metric adapters
won't work if you need advanced features
like these the open source distribution
may be the way to go for you if not
let's have a look at a managed asm
deployment and how its telemetry is
automatically ingested into cloud
operations
let's again start by looking at our
cluster
in this case we don't actually have any
istio control plane pods running in the
istio system namespace
the control plane is entirely managed by
google and there are no control plane
components running in the cluster itself
our application pods however are still
instrumented with the istio proxy
sidecar container
now let's have a look at the collected
telemetry
[Music]
just like before we can look at the
services running in our cluster
for all of them we can get the same
basic telemetry including the topology
view
we can get the same metric telemetry
and we can get the same access logs all
of this is made available via the
managed control plane without the need
to have anything running in the cluster
itself
thanks so much for watching today we
learned how a service mesh improves
observability for distributed workloads
around gke and how you can use cloud
operations to get telemetry from both
open source istio and the enthalpy
service mesh to observe your own
services i hope this helps you to keep
your applications reliable and your
users happy don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out on more
engineering for reliability with google
cloud see you soon
[Music]
you